es la ley de urgente consideración pero
todos los uruguayos la conocen por sus
siglas look un paquete de más de 470
artículos que han generado polémica en
la nación oriental el parlamento la
aprobó en marzo de 2020 con la coalición
de gobierno pero la oposición de
izquierda los sindicatos y varias
organizaciones de derechos humanos
consideraron que 135 artículos eran
intolerables por lo que convocaron un
referendo para su derogación esto es una
cuestión de una ley que hace que esta
que está imbuida de una práctica que
para nosotros no favorece la democracia
entre los puntos más controvertidos este
enorme ley limita el derecho a la huelga
flexibiliza el uso de la fuerza policial
y habilita los desalojos rápidos pero
que el ejecutivo de la pau ha defendido
férreamente hoy hace un año
8 meses y 14 días
que la luz que está vigente está entre
nosotros atrás derecho positivo ya nos
regulan y los perjuicios que se
anunciaban de manera grandilocuente y
con bombos y platillos no han sucedido
tras la pandemia el país que tiene mejor
calidad de vida de sudamérica ha sufrido
un aumento en la inflación y sus
ciudadanos han perdido poder adquisitivo
batería de recortes que se están dando
[Música]
preocupado por las empresas
que por entrar con las personas que te
está pasando a mí
y los expertos ya han avisado que las
leyes que se pretenden derogar podrían
ser aprobadas individualmente más
adelante en el parlamento no obstante la
resolución sobre la luz es una prueba de
fuego para la popularidad del ejecutivo
de lacalle pou